Build it. Draw it. Play it.
Vsauce! This is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people. This
is BiDiPi.
Build it
Seamster at instructables.com made this R2-D2
or the R2 double D2 bra as he likes to call
it, equipped with lights and sounds! Made
from paper mache and the lights and sounds
from an old R2 D2 toy. He also has an easier
duct tape version for novice crafters.Find
the link below.
Calvin Seibert has taken the art of making
sandcastles to the next level with these geometric
shapes. He says it's like a test because nature
is always against you and time is always running
out. He starts by making the basic shapes
with his hands and uses a simple plastic spackle
tool to do the precision work. And he works
on them until the tides come and wash them
away leaving him a clean new canvas.
Tony Swatton is a blacksmith that recreates
weapons from TV shows and movies. Here he
is forging the sword of Jamie Lanister from
Game of Thrones. Others include he man's sword,
batmans batarangs, raphaels sais, oddjobs
hat, and finns golden sword. Check out his
fantastic youtube channel for more.
Draw It
Artist StarRovias re creates modern day video
games into old school Atari cartridges. Including
Skyrim, Fallout3, grand theft auto, minecraft,
and mass effect. Check out the full collection
at her deviant art page.
Artist Adam Spizak makes some amazing illustrations
of popular TV characters such as Dexter, Rick
from walking dead, Don from Mad Men, and Walter
from Breaking Bad. All are available to purchase
so check out the website in the link below.
And now for the SNL inspired art of the "Is
this thing on? Too" art show.
Play it
Ezequiel Galasso of Buenos Aires makes guitars
out of used trashed up skateboard decks, Check
it out here in action.
Mega popular violinist Lindsey Sterling and
the incredible voice of Peter Hollens combine
to cover the theme from Game Of Thrones.
Finally, my good friends BarelyPolitical make
a tribute to ridiculous singing voices in
their new video with CDZA...
Submit your own BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube. Or share them with everyone
at facebook.com/vsaucetwo.
Click here to listen to bidipi radio. Music
created and submitted by you guys. Also check
out Your BiDiPi - an entire video dedicated
to your creations. And as always... thanks
for watching.